hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in section seven
and eight of his essay the will to
believe William James is going to talk
about risks and these risks are tied to
our beliefs should we in fact take on
and going further than that act upon
beliefs or should we hold ourselves back
to not embrace them to say I'm not sure
which I should actually trust and one of
the people who he's engaging with is an
interlocutor here
William Clifford said that it's always
wrong to believe anything without having
sufficient evidence James is going to
question that and he's doing that by
carrying out an analysis of what's going
on when we do commit ourselves in one
way or another or we have desires or
fears going on when it comes to these
epistemological questions of beliefs and
he begins section seven by saying that
there are two great Commandments and we
could call these epistemological norms
or imperatives right things that have to
do with with knowledge he says that one
of these is to know the truth
and the other is to avoid error now he
he also points out that you might think
that these are basically two sides of
the same coin so that they amount to the
same thing by knowing the truth you of
course you avoid error right you're not
falling into it and by avoiding error
you're in some way knowing the truth
about something aren't you well not
exactly you can avoid error and never
arrive at the truth as he says so he's
got this great passage he says we must
know the truth we must avoid error these
are our first and great Commandments as
would be no errs but they are not two
ways of stating an identical commandment
they are two as he calls them separable
laws they're describing two different
ways of orienting ourselves so he says
it may sometimes happen when we believe
truth a we escape an incidental
consequence from believing false would
be right if I believe that you're in the
car waiting for me to drive me to the
airport then you know if that happens to
be true
I'm prevented from believing that you're
actually in the airport looking for me
because you can't be in two places at
the same time but that's incidental as
he says he also goes on and says it
hardly ever happens that merely Bible
disbelieving be we necessarily believe a
we may in escaping be fallen to other
falsehoods C or D just as bad as B or we
may escape B by not believing anything
at all not even a the thing that's
actually true and we see this so often
in our lives don't we that a person will
you know make it clear that they at
least they don't buy into this thing
over here and you're like yeah but you
could you believe this complete nonsense
over here in place of that or they they
you know pride themselves on their
critical thinking or being logical or
evidence-based and they never actually
see the things that are staring them in
the face the truths that they could in
fact know now James says a little bit
further down
that these these injunctions are
actually what he calls expressions of
our passional life he says these
feelings of duty about either truth or
error are stemming from this greater
penumbra or you can think of it as
foundation of our effective life which
includes desires Volition's feelings all
these these things habits as he says the
circum pressure of our cast and set all
these things that are strictly speaking
non rational non-intellectual elements
or dynamics that applies to these as
well what happens if we select one of
these over the other he says we can go
one of two ways we can prioritize
finding truth over avoiding error or we
can prioritize avoiding error over
finding truth and which one we choose is
going to stem from again our passional
or volitional or wheeling nature as he
says so we can regard the chase for
truth is paramount and the avoidance of
error is second or secondary we can
treat the avoidance of error as more
imperative and that truth tickets its
chance clifford represents this second
way of doing things in an extreme way
because james says we do need to in some
cases focused primarily on avoiding
error james is arguing in this essay for
at least in some cases prioritizing
finding truth over avoiding error and
whereas clifford could be seen as an
extreme case of the second injunction
are imperative james is positioning
himself as a moderate case of the first
he's not embracing prioritizing finding
truth over avoiding error in every
single situation as a matter of fact he
makes fun of the law clerks in part
because they think it's more important
to stamp things decided then to have
them actually be true or not let's take
a look closely at that for just a moment
he says law courts have to decide on the
best evidence attainable for the moment
because of
duty is to make law as well as to
ascertain it and as a learner judge once
said to me few cases are worth spending
much time over the great thing is to
have them decided on any acceptable
principle and got out of the way so the
idea there is let's let's just get this
stuff done because we have a heavy
caseload ahead and in that case it's not
so much seeking the truth it's more like
well let's let's establish some truth
and get it get it finished with that
would be excessive in this case so what
are the ways in which we can understand
these these two stances let's actually
take a look at the second one first
prioritizing avoiding error over finding
truth what is the risk inherent in this
well the risk is of not finding or not
accepting or not acting upon the truth
when you actually have the possibility
of finding it so you know a little bit
later in the essay James will give the
example of romantic life if you're going
to wait for irrefutable objective
evidence before you think that somebody
is attracted to you let alone loves you
and therefore it could be a suitable
dating partner or potential mate well
you're never going to make a decision
because any anything along those lines
you can find some counter example or
some way of describing the behavior in
you know by appealing to other motives
or things like that so you'll never
actually make a decision and you will
definitely keep yourself free from the
error of believing that somebody loves
you when they don't but you will also
deprive yourself of the truth of finding
out that somebody loves you when they do
and we could talk about all sorts of
other examples as well this job would be
suited to you well I don't know with a
hundred percent certainty that it would
be you never really know about a job
until you get there and start doing it
maybe the co-workers are mean maybe the
boss is a psychopath
maybe the company
you know not reporting its financial
figures accurately of all these things
are possible and you could say well I'm
not going to commit to that job I'm not
going to embrace that hypothesis I'm not
going to take that option and therefore
I will miss out on that truth so that is
a significant issue and James talks
about Clifford here and says that
Clifford is in some ways being if not
inconsistent at least rather selective
in what he's making his basis he says
Clifford in the instructive passage
which I have quoted exhorts us to take
the latter course treat the avoidance of
errors more imperative believe nothing
he says keep your mind in suspense
forever rather than by closing and on
insufficient evidence incur the awful
risk of believing lies and then James
says you on the other hand may think the
risk of being an heir is a small matter
when compared to the blessings of real
knowledge and be ready to be duped many
times in your investigation rather than
postponed indefinitely the chance of
guessing true and he says I find it
impossible to go with Clifford why
because this stems from our passional
life Clifford is ignoring the fact that
he has this horror of finding himself in
the condition of having embraced a
falsehood not everybody's so bothered by
that and James goes on and says he who
says better to go without belief forever
than mere me then believed a lie merely
shows his own preponderant private
horror of becoming a dupe and here's the
clincher he may be critical of many of
his desires and fears but this fear he
slavishly obeys and this is what he's
saying that Clifford is doing a little
bit later James points out that well two
things one is maybe falling into error
is not the worst thing that could ever
happen to a person it takes a certain
kind of individual to think that it
actually is the worst thing that could
happen to you and it's a kind of a rare
sort isn't it although we do find
people like this in many different modes
the other thing that he points out he
uses an analogy here is that this is
sort of like a general or any sort of
military officer who refuses to use
their soldiers it says it's like a
general informing his soldiers it's
better to keep out of battle for ever
than to risk a single wound and you
could say well what is the point of
generals and soldiers then they don't
really serve much of a purpose do they
let's talk about the second possibility
that of boldly prioritizing finding
truth over avoiding error well there are
some risks involved with this as well
right we risk accepting falsehoods we
risk falling into believing things that
we don't actually have sufficient
evidence for when should we do this so
here's where James's distinction between
options becomes particularly important
when we have a genuine option that
cannot be decided solely by intellectual
means or processes then we probably need
to prioritize finding truth and take
that risk of falling into falsehood he
says we ought to risk this when options
are live
that is they appeal to us our passional
nature when they're momentous if we
don't do it now if we don't take the
risk we're going to miss out and when
they're forced when we either have to
accept it or reject it or you could say
accept it or do anything other than
accept it and James says that this is
not the case all the time as a matter of
fact prioritizing avoiding error over
fighting truth James says that this is
how science in general makes progress
although he does have a proviso here he
says that the person is totally
uncommitted isn't really going to be
very good at you know coming up with
hypotheses and testing them it does
require some passion to do science well
but prioritizing avoiding error those he
says make
since when the options are trivial when
they're not living when they're not
forced so he says that in scientific
questions this is almost always the case
and in human affairs in general the need
of acting is seldom so urgent that a
false belief to act on is better than no
belief at all so he tells us that you
know in our dealings with objective
nature we are not makers of the truth we
are more recorders of the truth and when
we're looking at physical nature the
questions here are always trivial
options the hypotheses are hardly living
and the choice between believing truth
or falsehood is seldom for so he says
the attitude of sceptical balance is the
absolutely wise one if we want to avoid
mistakes so James is not saying that we
all have to select one of these and just
stick with it all the time we want to
you might say make a meta decision
between prioritizing one of these two
approaches from situation to situation
and subject matter to subject matter
you